[Applause]
i'm happy to be here
in boca raton uh with my newest
guest i'm absolutely honored and
thrilled to have with us today
richard verner he is a member of lineker
college
at the university of oxford uh and he's
also a university
professor in banking and finance i'm
going to let him get into his cv because
it's
gigantic the abridged version of his
education
is that he holds a degree from the
london school of economics
and a doctorate from oxford where he
intersected with destiny
once he gives us his cv that's where i
want to start i want to start on the
ground
in tokyo in the summer of 1989
where you were poised to witness history
as we know it but first
tell us a little bit more about where
you teach
i teach in in england at de montfort
university in leicester
and also i've been asked to teach
in shanghai at fudan university i have
also
a number of more short-term invitations
to a number of universities and of
course i'm also
very much interested in financial
markets i'm an
um uk regulated asset manager
i've run global macro funds including
for best earns asset management
um and i'm for the last few years
um essentially my hobby has been to set
up
community banks in the uk
we will talk more about that because you
do have another book
out there uh that is not princess of the
yen
where you explore deeply what happened
in the united kingdom with its property
markets with its banking system
and and we'll get to that because i
think there are probably many parallels
to be drawn
uh but first let's take a walk back in
time you hear the anecdotes
uh pebble beach and all of the trophy
properties
and the the massive outflow of money
that left tokyo in the imperial palace
was
worth as much as the state of california
you hear these things
but it's impossible to to put them in
your mind
if you weren't there but you were there
what was it like you were there before
the bubble burst
and what took you there that's true well
um
well what took me there was uh that i
couldn't go to china to shanghai to
fudan university because i had a place
there to learn chinese it was a bit
ahead of of things at the time
because it was still um you know the
iron curtain hadn't fallen
but i i thought china is going to rise
and i want to learn chinese but it
wasn't possible suddenly in 89
for various reasons if you go back um
martial law declare and things like that
i went to tokyo uh initially for
deutsche bank and that was
in in the summer of 1989 at the peak of
the
japanese legendary gigantic
stock market bubble um
and um yeah i saw that at close range
in the end um just so you see what
where this was the leading out i ended
up staying in japan for quite a while
uh in total 12 years um various doors
opened i was at the university of tokyo
i was the first shimumura fellow
at the japan development bank one of the
government
banks that had been involved in the high
growth era in japan establishing
post-war
recovery and very high growth for
several decades
and then i was at the bank of japan
that's why i had my
introduction into central banking you
know what was it like in 89 well
one important feature is if you think
back
nobody called it a bubble at the time
it wasn't considered a bubble it was
just you know
that's the situation that's the level of
stock prices and land prices it's japan
and remember
the stories how japan was going to take
over the world and it's going to be the
next 21st century
is going to be the japanese century
japanese money had been flooding
out of the country um across the
the world in the 1980s
and of course people tend to extrapolate
from these past trends
and you know then it was just all the
way up for japan
um but that was clearly not gonna happen
um and i just come back from japan in 91
the stock market had fallen quite a bit
um down by you know
by almost um well but over 20
30 percent approaching 50 so big big
falls but
the economy was still
expanding gdp growth was seven percent
seven percent
interest rates were around seven percent
as well
short rates long rates um and so what
was everyone saying well the bank of
japan came out in 91 and was saying
okay we're going to lower interest rates
and so for everyone just based on the
standard
analysis and all the strategies were
coming out and we're saying well buy
japanese stocks
because well the economy is clearly
strong we know japan's strong good
fundamentals
companies are strong the stock market
has fallen
so much and now they're lowering rates
and of course the traditional standard
analysis conventional analysis is
if you've got lower interest rates
that's good for the economy it's good
for stock markets
that's what they're doing and they had a
long way to lower them which they did
follow
um now that's the moment that my first
paper uh was published at
back at oxford when i just come back in
september
october 91 and my conclusion
was the opposite namely
and and also remember at the time the
top 20 banks in the world
were all japanese banks by assets you
know these huge balance sheets
um and my conclusion was
don't buy japanese stocks japanese banks
are likely to go bankrupt and japan is
likely to move into the biggest
recession since the great depression
they were sort of written up in the
economist i had the job offers went back
to tokyo then and
93 started as chief economist early 94
with british firm jardine fleming
securities since it's been bought up by
jp morgan
and my thesis was
that essentially what has created the
bubble
was switching into reverse and was going
to crush the banking system
but for a long time people thought this
can't be true it's impossible and i was
really amazed by how long people
hung on to the old story of the great
japan
and the economy is going to be strong
it's just a small dip
and you know the the fundamentals are so
strong
to me it was quite obvious and you know
i guess we should talk about the
mechanism i saw behind this because that
really taught me about how economies
everywhere work
it's the banking system and how central
banks really interact there
with the banking system and how um the
the credit mechanism in the banking
system is the core
mechanism and all that was was all
contracting
um i put out an estimate in
in the early 90s of the size of the bad
debts i was expecting in the banking
system now in those days people had
tiny tiny forecasts of bad debts it
wasn't really a topic bad that's in the
banking system
um and my forecast was well it's going
to be
in percentages around
25 of bank balance sheets
which also made it a you know
approximately um
similar percentage of gdp you know one
year's annual gdp
so substantial because we know capital
is usually
10 or less for the bigger banks less
than 10 percent
so certainly anything above 10 in bad
debts
is the end of the banking system really
that's insolvency
exactly um now ironically by the end of
the decade of the 1990s
um everyone had become so negative on
japan
they had bad debt estimates which were
much larger than my original ones from
the early 90s
and and then i was told you know this is
wildly too large
but by the end the consensus has become
so negative
but if you go back and actually check
the figures my original figures were the
correct ones
it was around 80 trillion yen in bad
debts
and not more not less how could i
calculate this
very easy very simple calculation um
and it goes back to my the mechanism
that created the bubble and that was
going to now create this this
uh bust and long recession which
is really the the mechanism at the at
the core of all economies
it's the money creation mechanism where
does money come from
and it's funny because when you study
economics as i've done
i mean in any discipline whether it's
chemistry or physics or whatever you
know
you study it at the top universities you
expect
to become an expert in the important
stuff in your discipline
but when you study economics they don't
really teach you about
the money creation process and the
monetary mechanism
because the leading economic theories
and models as you know i mean they
the the hybrid ones they don't even have
any money whatsoever in their model
um it's an abstracted um theoretical
economy where essentially people
exchange things
by a barter that's what they assume
because money doesn't matter
so we might as well take it out of the
equation it just confuses things
i mean there's the famous book by david
roma
in fact i did a survey what what's in in
the uk at british universities
what is the most widely used
master's level uh macroeconomics
textbook and it was david romer
you know it's his key book on
macroeconomics and growth
and and on page three it says um
you know essentially for more than half
in the in the book we
the models and theories don't include
money because this would only confuse
matters
so we heard from jay powell just a few
days ago
that it was no longer an appropriate
part it was
no longer an appropriate mechanism for
central banks to look at the money
supply
and that is that is the orthodoxy yeah
yes indeed indeed but but really it's
it's surprising that he says this now at
this
late stage because certainly since 2008
a lot of people have realized that oh
you know we neglected
the monetary mechanism and and really
um we can't just exclude money
uh we have to understand how it works
and where money comes from
and that was also my original puzzle
when i was shimomura fellow in tokyo in
1991 and i had this
this task to my research topic
uh on the basis of which i became the
first shimomura fellow was
to figure out japanese capital flows
that were buying up the world as you've
started out mentioning you know japanese
money buying
pebbles uh golf course um rockefeller
center
um columbia pictures whatever in
australia in hawaii
and in the uk they were buying up
companies
real estate whatever you name it
um and it was just so much money that no
standard economic model could explain it
all the world's experts were saying we
don't know there is no answer
somebody told me oh there's this you
know famous u.s
economist jeffrey sachs he was recently
in tokyo at
meaty the ministry of industry and trade
with his i think former phd's and peter
boone and they've written a paper on
just this topic
richard you should go and and speak to
meaty they will have the paper
and i went there met various bureaucrats
and they told me yes yeah
uh professor sax and peter boone they
were here oh yes we have their
discussion paper
which they presented and it was because
my fundamental idea was
it's clearly linked to these crazy asset
prices
land prices where the imperial palace
garden had as you said
the same value as the entire state of
california including los angeles san
francisco you name it
crazy um and so that there had to be a
link but what precisely was the link
there was the paper jeffrey sacks peter
boone
i was delighted because you know i was
just i barely finished my
my first degree at the lse by the end of
it
i was very disappointed to find there is
no link that was their conclusion
there is no link why the argument was
well okay you've got totally overpriced
japanese real estate to the extent that
it makes sense for
japanese land owners to just sell a tiny
plot of land
and buy you know buy a few big chunks of
california why not
you know just for diversification
purpose alone would make sense and that
would give you the mechanism
but they were arguing well hang on even
if you did that which seems perfectly
rational
this wouldn't affect um capital outflows
or the or the whole
you know monetary situation why because
who
you know if you own the land and you
want to cash in you've got to sell it
and who's buying it and foreigners were
not buying japanese land because it was
outlandishly expensive so it was only
other japanese who were buying the land
and therefore it's just money moving
from japanese owner a to japanese
land owner b and therefore plus minus
zero
international impact there shouldn't be
any international impact which was a
logical argument but richard
at the time he was known as a capital
flow expert and i told him about my
my job my task i need to find out what
is this link
between the property market and capital
flows or otherwise what
explains these capital flows and and he
told me look richard
forget it you won't be able to solve
this one it's too complicated
no nobody has a model that works
so but it didn't give up that was a
challenge
it certainly was a challenge i mean all
the experts were saying it
you know there is no link doesn't you
know do something else
you won't be able to crack to crack that
knot
so but the conclusion is that i
i did find out it's a very simple
insight
which at the same time answered so many
other questions as well
it goes straight to this money creation
process
the answer is that know that the land
owners
that want to cash in and diversify and
invest abroad they don't need to sell
their land
they just use it as collateral to borrow
money from a bank
but now comes the next step what happens
when you borrow money from a bank
what happens then all the finance
leading finance journals
and most textbooks will tell you well
banks are financial intermediaries they
gather deposits
they do their analysis on credit you
know evaluation and credit rating all
sorts and then they
use some of those deposits and lend it
out so their financial intermediaries
are just in between the depositors
and the final use of the money
but it's not true but the conclusion is
this is not actually what happens
when a bank gives out a loan banks are
not financial intermediaries
i could show this with data um
but empirically i i approve this only
much later
this is published only in 2014
where i did a separate empirical test
this is using
um german banking data because really
see
and this financial intermediation theory
is only one of three theories of banking
and it's extraordinary i mean banking
has been around for five thousand years
you go back to
ancient babylonia and there were
essentially modern banks there was a
credit economy
um there was interest being charged
there were um
collateralized loans uncollateralized
loans cashless
transactions you know it was a a proper
banking system because essentially
banking is accounting
and they kept good records and we have
them in the british museum
thousands and thousands of clay tablets
right in cuneiform where they
they note and they're mostly accounting
records and banking records
so banking is ancient yet until
recently there's been a debate
still an ongoing debate a controversial
debate about
how banks actually work and there's
these three theories of banking now
the one that i described is the dominant
one the conventional one that's
in all the textbooks and finance journal
journal of finance and
and so on journal of uh money credit and
banking
they think banks are financial
intermediaries
this is not based on on empirical
evidence by the way
now there's a second theory and that's
the older one and
um some people remember because that
used to be taught in the textbooks
also in economics namely the fractional
reserve theory of banking
which says that uh well a bank always
has to
um put a percentage um of the
of their deposits with the central bank
the fractional reserve and say it's
let's say
if it's one percent the bank gets a new
deposit of a hundred dollars
it will put one dollar with the central
bank and lend out 99 but the 99 will
then become somebody else's
some other banks new deposit when you
use it
and that bank will then put one percent
aside give it to the central bank as a
reserve and lend out 99
of that 98 point you know and so on
so the whole thing continues that will
then become
uh some other banks deposit each time
the amount gets smaller
and it's a geometric uh progression and
mathematically and you can calculate the
total
and with a one percent reserve
requirement the
100 initial deposit become 10
000 in aggregate in total deposits
the central bank has 100
as their total reserves from all the
banks these small amounts
and total new lending in the banking
system is 9900
that's the fractional reserve theory
it's sort of slightly complicated but
sort of also
i mean there's a certain logic to it
now that's not any more popular as as as
you may know
you may have noticed i mean nowadays
they they don't talk about this they
talk only about this
financial intermediation theory banks
are like non-banks there's no
no difference now there's a third theory
and that one is the oldest that one was
popular
from essentially well until roughly the
1920s 1930s that's when the
fraction reserve theory started to
become dominant until the 60s
then we had the financial intermediation
theory and this oldest theory
is the credit creation theory of banking
now that's the
the most surprising one and that one
says
banks are not financial intermediaries
they do not intermediate they're
actually creators of money
and when a bank gives out a loan
this is newly created money that's added
to the money supply but not
like in the fraction reserve story in
some kind of indirect collective
fashion where you can't kind of grasp
where's the money creation oh it's just
in the system it happens in sequence
no the credit creation theory says no
each individual bank
creates new money when when it gives out
a new loan
so these three theories they differ in
in terms of the question of when a bank
lends money where does the money come
from
and so recently i i thought and
obviously you know i i knew already in
the early 90s
the answer and used that in my work
quite successfully also as economist and
forecaster
we can come to that but i i also wanted
to end this debate
and the fact that even in this day and
age people still think banks are
financial intermediary so i conducted
um a few years ago the first empirical
test of this theory i mean that's the
scientific thing to do isn't it there's
three theories
they say different things what do we do
well we need an empirical test
published 2014 if you google
can banks individually create money out
of nothing
you'll get it it's the most downloaded
um
apparently academic uh paper in
in all the elsevier academic journals
across all the various disciplines
so made a bit of a splash when it came
out 2014 even the central banks then
came out bank of england oh yes banks
create money
we knew that we knew that well they knew
that but they didn't publicize it
so but uh let me tell you so this this
study
um was essentially um going to a bank
and and saying well this has to be real
so i'm really going to borrow money
because the three theories of banking
differ
on that point when you borrow money
where does this money come from so we're
going to go to the bank a really
functioning bank
we need access to their accounting
system and their
i.t essentially is all in the i.t isn't
it
we need access to that which was a bit
of a big hurdle because that's all
high security isn't that customer data
and and so on
but for scientific research i managed to
to get that the bbc was actually filming
um
as well and
the question then is so does the bank
when the bank gives out a loan so i
really borrowed money it was 200
000 euros which would be what
250 000 or something and i i told the
bankers
well no i want to transfer this away to
my
own bank account and another bank it
needs to be you know i really need to
get the money
otherwise i don't want to some kind of
simulation or theoretical stuff
has to be real so they were quite
nervous about this like
is this a quite a quite an elaborate
scam and this guy is just
going to run with this money um
and so then we did this and the question
then was
when i get the money booked to my
account
um where does the bank get the money
from is it from
um from deposits
customer deposits as the financial
intimidation theory claims
or is it from excess reserves at say at
the central bank as the fractional
reserve theory says
because without excess reserves you
can't do the new lending or
is it just you know create it out of
nothing out of thin
air invented and
well the conclusion was the money was
invented
the deposits didn't change the reserves
they didn't even check how much do we
have in reserves and
was was uh untouched
um and it was simply newly credited to
me now if you look at the legal side for
those who are interested in this
question
from the legal perspective it's actually
um
it's most clear you know clearly visible
what's what's going on
because what the bank really does is
when you
when you get a loan a mortgage whatever
the moment you sign the loan contract
that
can be considered and the bank does
consider it as
a promissory note that you've written in
other words it's security it's an iou
that you've issued as the borrower of
course
and you promise it's a promise to pay
you to repay this money
so really you've issued a security like
when the you know the the government
issues treasuries you've issued your
your loan your mortgage treasury your
security okay
the bank now says okay we're gonna buy
that
and it puts it on its balance sheet as
an asset because now they have a claim
on you because you promise to repay this
money
and you say at this point actually i
don't care about these details just give
me the money
and if the banker is careful the banker
will say
you will find it in your account with us
they may carelessly say oh we've
transferred it to your account that
would be technically wrong because no
transfer takes place that's what i
confirmed in that
empirical experiment that when i got the
money it was not transferred from any
other account i mean you know you can
see
where does it come from and it didn't
come from any other account
inside the bank or outside the bank
so what is it well at law because the
bank has has
got your promissory note it also
according to the loan contract of course
owes you money
as well right that's the money that you
want in the first place that's why you
went to the bank for the loan
now that means there is an accounts
payable liability that the bank has
because you know it hasn't paid you but
it needs to pay you
and therefore on its liability side of
the balance sheet it will also record
the same amount that it's already
recorded as an asset
when it bought your iou say two hundred
thousand dollars
but they also owe you two hundred
thousand dollars and accounts payable
liability and now is the little trick
they will book this as a liability on
that balance sheet
but of a different category they won't
actually
say oh it's an accounts payable
liability arising from the loan contract
that's really the truth well it puts it
in plain english
yes exactly it puts in plain english um
this other paper is called
how how do banks create money and why
can other firms not do the same you can
also google it as open access as well
and so what they do is they don't book
it as an accounts payable liability
which would be correct they book it as
a liability of another type namely a
customer claim on the bank
that they call a bank deposit
because what is a bank deposit it's a
claim by customers on the bank and this
is
an english law well established for
centuries
that there is no such thing as a bank
deposit it that's not a legal concept
doesn't exist
all there is is a loan we've given to
the bank so deposits actually loans that
we've given to the bank
and that's what they put in their lot on
their liabilities well
we owe their money that's how we record
it now the bank's
record of the bank's debt to the public
that's what we call bank deposits and
that's our money supply
and so of course they can invent it out
of nothing and so then suddenly when you
look at the legal side
it's not so magical or surprising that
of course they can create money because
really they're just adding more
liabilities they have and because
the banking license gives them the right
to
put things on their balance sheet accept
deposits
the banking license really allows us to
accept deposits that means they can
invent new liabilities on themselves
which they do when they give out a loan
now of course the borrower has no idea
about
these details right and they think well
i've got money here because look i've
got it in my um
bank account current account it's there
and i've transferred to somebody else
and nobody realizes that that's just
being newly invented by the bank
on the back of the bank purchasing your
iou and as banks do
more of that the money supply expands
and this is where
actually now we're at the core question
because now i come back to japan and the
capital flows and everything
so if banks
lend money they they create new money
they expand the money supply
and the key question now is what is this
money going to be used for
and this has a massive impact on
everything in the system
if banks were just financial
intermediaries it wouldn't really matter
that much
and it's true for for real non-bank
financial intermediaries whether
insurance companies or asset management
companies
it's money in here money out there
that's just shifting existing money that
doesn't have a macro impact
but we're talking about money creators
and the central bank only creates three
percent of the money supply
it's the banks that create 97 percent of
the money supply
so therefore their decision of who gets
the money and how much money they get
and
what are they going to use the money for
that
reshapes the economic landscape in a
very short time period
now there's the simplest way to analyze
this is essentially there's three
scenarios
if a bank creates new money
and it's used for
asset purchases then
what happens if the bank was a financial
intermediary
nothing much would happen because the
money's pulled out somewhere else and
it's shifted into assets it's a shift
but when the bank prints new money
because that's what it is like money
printing
bank credit creation bank lending and
the asset purchase takes place with
you know bank lending being the source
of funds
then you have created new money
injecting this new money into the real
estate market for example
you're going to push up real estate
prices and the same with asset prices
so when banks lend for asset purchases
you're pushing up asset prices that
explains the 1980s asset bubble
this is always unsustainable always well
it seems like
though um at least if you look at the
american experience
it it seems as if this process
has been going on for a very very long
time
very true i mean we've had interest
rates declining for
more than 40 years at this point and
if you look at the long-term trends in
the asset markets
uh clearly there have been a a few bumps
along the way but it has been
a very steady rise basically since
interest rates peaked in 1981
so and that's and that's what i really
want to get to is
yes where is where do the parallels come
about with the united states
exactly what's happening right now
exactly and
and you're right it's it's been quite an
amazing
long acid bubble in the u.s there was a
bit of a blip 2008 2009 but the us was
the first
to recover and it's for the same reasons
and so
um so we need to answer that question um
so let me just um outline the other two
scenarios so one is when banks lend for
asset purchases
and that creates asset inflation and
that can go on for many many years
as long essentially it's a big ponzi
scheme you know
it will continue as long as banks
continue to create
credit for asset purchases that's the
condition
the moment that stops is like this um
you know uh children's game where you go
around the
around the room and you've got the
chairs there musical chairs right
while the music is on they walk around
but you've taken away
one or two chairs they have to sit down
when the music stops and there aren't
enough chairs
and it's exactly that so you know
bankers have used this metaphor
essentially you know when
um who was it prince chuck prince said
the music is playing we're still dancing
you know
the music is there they're creating
credit we have to play the game and it's
rational
therefore for everyone to stay in the
game because you're earning money but
you also have to be aware the moment the
music stops
it's going to be a rush for the door
because there aren't enough seats
because asset prices will not rise
anymore and the late comers that bought
very
expensively and they need further
capital gains just to
you know service and repay the loans
they won't get them they will go bust
you have non-performing assets
and that then leads to this downward
spiral where the banks then restrict
lending further
which pushes down asset prices further
which creates more bankruptcies more
non-performing loans this of course what
happened in japan
but it's also what happened um in in
many other
countries um in europe we had the same
situation in ireland portugal spain and
greece for instance in the 2000s
so the second one is when banks create
credit
for consumption now that's the one that
most people think of
money creation money printing inflation
turns out that's only one of three
fundamental scenarios
and you know when we had the so-called
great moderation in the us
um there was a massive expansion in the
money supply
but there was no inflation there was no
consumer price inflation why
well it was money creation bank credit
creation for asset purchases it was the
acid bubble it wasn't really a
moderation it's just
that's where you had your inflation acid
inflation
but it is true that when banks create
credit for consumption
you will get consumer price inflation
that's something we need to talk about
because 2020
2021 uh this is you know the mechanism
is now in place for that to become
uh quite prominent thirdly though
there's a third scenario and this is
really the
the redeeming feature of the banking
system and it is why the us economy
really if you look
look back for 200 years has been one of
the strongest economies
uh in the world and why other countries
that have also
been very successful in the last 200
years like germany
and then last 100 years japan last 50
years
china they've done the same namely the
following
you ensure that the majority of your
bank
credit your money creation in the
banking system bank credit creation
is used not for asset purchases is used
not for consumption
but is used for business investment
that's the the golden rule of banking if
you ensure that
most of bank credit creation money
creation is used for business investment
in productive
investments that expand productivity
implement new technologies
uh increase goods and services create
new products that have value
of course there will always be failures
but overall it's a very of a different
kind from asset purchases property and
finance
or consumption you know so as long as
that's the majority of your money
creation
is actually for business investment and
of course
the biggest employer in all these
countries also the us
are small firms small firms are the most
important employer
it's around um 70 of employment in
in the us in the uk and japan in germany
germany and japan actually it's close to
80 even
now these small firms they always credit
ration they don't need bank loans
they can't use you know the stock market
and so on
so they need bank lending and if you
have bank lending for productive
purposes
ideally to small firms you will get
economic growth and no inflation
that's quite quite an extraordinary
insight because
we can have very high growth and no
inflation there's almost no limit to
economic growth
hang on some people say hang on aren't
there limits to growth didn't the club
of rome tell us
you know climate change and all that
we've got limits to growth
well not really actually there's a lot
of misunderstandings clearly we should
all
be careful to to treat the environment
well
and things like pollution and
environmental degradation is bad
but growth as such is not the enemy
because what is growth growth can't be
the enemy because growth is an
accounting fiction
it's just an accounting fiction there is
no economic growth you know ask a
physicist
you know tell me what's economic growth
how is the economy growing the physicist
will tell you no there's no growth we
know that
the laws of thermodynamics you know it's
all the same you're just transforming
energy from one state to another
but there's no growth that can't be
growth so we've created this accounting
fiction by
taking out certain statistical series
putting them together we call it gdp the
national income accounts
and that's what we're monitoring but gdp
as such is not
hurting the environment you know it's
not um
it is bad activities that can hurt the
environment we should avoid those that's
you know that's fine but it doesn't mean
we have to have zero growth or negative
growth so we can have actually very high
growth the us has shown that in the past
when it was an emerging market it was
growing at very high economic growth
rates china has shown this for 40 years
double-digit economic growth
is possible and they did it by making
sure bank credit
was guided essentially mainly for
productive business investment they
they stepped in they said no bank credit
for asset purchases and no bank credit
for consumption
um of course recently you know the last
10 years they've liberalized that
but that's how you get very high growth
well but if
so if you look back at at the decade
leading up to
the financial crisis the banks in the
united states were lending for the
purpose of
buying assets productivity has
declined during that period if you look
at the last 12 years
some of the slowest gdp growth and banks
have been
lending effectively to financialize
uh we haven't been investing uh we
haven't been growing the economy
we've been going the opposite direction
of china and we've seen this
play out in productivity figures in the
united states
i mean this really does bring china into
focus because even though you look at
the two countries and you see these
very high debt to gdp ratios
one of the debts has been created for
naught and another one has
built a lot of things created a lot of
investments created a lot of future
growth so but so i'm you're drawing me
back again and again to
what what are the consequences for the
united states having two entire
economic cycles that were non-productive
in terms of
the credit creation what happens where
do we go
exactly that you've identified the
problem
it is a problem not just for the us the
uk is similar and
the uk government you know they they put
out every year or so
big reports about how the the problem is
such low productivity why is uk
productivity
declining and so on and they can't
figure it out but it's exactly
the mechanism that you've mentioned um
and well
should we answer the question by looking
at at a country that still has very high
productivity despite for years people
saying oh
productivity will go down and that's
germany and let's look at small firms
because they're the biggest employer now
there is a category of small firms that
are
very very successful they're so
successful that they
um they essentially dominate the world
market in their
market niche of course it would be a
very specialized market niche
but they're like number one in market
share in the world or number two or
number three
you know taking this from the olympics
so gold silver bronzer we've got the
champions
and people have done research on this
and they call them the hidden champions
this is when in small or medium-sized
enterprise using the international
classification of size you know either
by capital or staff or turnover
they are small and because they're small
nobody knows them like they're not brand
names they're not bmw
or you know siemens or toyota of that
type
it's just people have won't have heard
of these names
and they're also very specialized so
they're called
hidden champions and that's the
definition if a small firm
is global market leader
in in place one two or three these top
three places in terms of market share
in the world in their market niche then
they're a hidden champion and i have to
be smes of course we're not talking
about big companies
so they meet the sme small medium-sized
enterprise
definition now then you look at the
world
people have done this research which
country has the largest number of hidden
champions
and turns out to be germany by a wide
distance number two is the us
the us has 320 apparently um
hidden champions small firms that are
world leaders
uh in their market niche but are small
that's 320s that's pretty good there's
number two in the world number one is
germany with 1 500.
so um and the other countries are sort
of 30 40 50 max even china
you know they have much smaller numbers
so why is this how is this possible that
and in germany germany has as many
exports
as china it's just slightly below china
which is why china is number one
but it's almost the same absolute amount
of course the chinese population is 30
times as large so
per capita germany is way out exporting
china even
and almost half of these exports are
these small firms
how is that possible how on earth is it
possible well
it has to do with money and finance and
productivity
because clearly to be top 123 market
share
player you you're going to be very
productive you have to be extremely
competitive
and you can only do this if you have
implemented the latest technology
now technology is something that is
there these small firms don't develop
the technology
you know uh researchers develop the
technology there's universities there's
international research doesn't even have
to be in germany
um information is available nowadays
more than ever before
but why do these small firms manage to
implement the latest technology
and therefore they're so productive and
they can beat the competitors
what would you need to do that you know
you need money
and who gives money to small firms
not big banks because big banks want to
do big deals with big customers i did a
study with one of my phd students it's
now
published actually um
um in the um in one of the the top
finance
journals journal of international money
and uh finance
jim we looked at u.s data
because the u.s has the largest number
of banks and has many small banks also
very large banks and the
simple question was how does the size of
the bank affect their lending
and the simple answer we found was well
what do you expect the big banks do big
deals
who lends to small firms it's the small
banks
that have a higher propensity to lend to
small firms which
is of course common sense but had to be
demonstrated
so germany has 1500
small local community banks out of its
total 1
800 banks so 80 percent of all german
banks are small
local community banks actually most of
them not for profit even
they're either local public savings
banks or cooperative banks stakeholder
banks
but they're very professionally run and
they have one rule
they only lend to companies in their
footprint
area which is usually quite a small area
they will not lend outside if there's no
link to their geographical area
and that's good for them because each
has their own turf they know their
customers really well
and they know they're in the same boat
with their customers you know if they're
the firms in their local area go down
well that's bad for the bank as you can
imagine
they make sure that these local firms
become
champions in their market share and they
give them the funding to implement the
latest technology and that's what we
need that's what of course
all small firms need in the whole world
and the small firms are the biggest
employer more than
two-thirds of employment in all
countries so what we need there for is
small banks
and then you get high growth now in the
us and so back to your question about
this financialization the number of
banks
if i could interrupt for a minute
absolutely everything you've described
is the united states is going in the
opposite way we've got oligopolies this
is back to the robert
robert baron era we've got small banks
dissolving
we have policy post pandemic that really
has
you know taken small businesses to the
slaughterhouse we are
we're doing absolutely the opposite of
everything you're describing
yeah yeah unfortunately exactly and that
is the answer to your question namely
this increased trend of financialization
um asset bubbles essentially instead of
productive investment
so then the international productivity
of u.s companies goes down
they need to upgrade particularly the
small firms they need money to fund
implementation of the latest
technologies and they they can't get the
money
um that's the same in the uk we have
five big banks dominating in the uk's is
very extreme here in england
and the small firms don't get the
funding
in the u.s there still are small banks
but it's a historic
thing i mean there used to be many many
more there used to be over 30
000 banks in the us now we only have 5
and declining over the last 25 years
um over 5000 banks have disappeared
it's similar to the to the eurozone the
ecb
has taken very similar policies since
the european central bank has been
created this is only 20 years 21 years
or so
4 800 banks have disappeared
so what we see is that the the central
banks
have taken policies in many countries
and the fed and the ecb are particularly
blatant in this um that kill
small banks that encourage bank mergers
the ecb is very open about it certainly
is not a conspiracy because
the ecb has said loudly and on the
record we have too many banks in the
eurozone and
you know europe is overbanked we need to
get rid of banks
what we found in this u.s study is that
as small banks
over time merge and get larger we had a
20-year time period
already then you notice the problem that
even the small banks that used to help
the small
firms as they get bigger they also lend
to bigger companies
that means that even under normal
circumstances we constantly need to
create
new small banks really but what's what
the central banks have been doing is the
opposite they'd be actually actively
reducing the number of banks
and therefore making all the banks
bigger fewer bigger banks
and too big to fail and that's so
extraordinary isn't it because in 2008
there was a lot of discussion about this
um and it was the big topic it was clear
that it's not good to have
a small number of too big to fail banks
and it's not good for regulators it's
not good for financial stability
and we should all avoid it and everyone
was agreeing and there's no disagreement
yet all the policies taken sense
by the big policy makers which is the
basel committee on banking
bank regulation and the the central
banks the bank regulators the
governments in in europe brussels
law for for banking all that
essentially had the effect
of making life hard and impossible for
small banks and was
forcing banks to merge so they
introduced
massive over regulation that for the big
banks meant they have to hire now
another 1 000 compliance officers
but a small bank with 20 staff they
can't afford to have
two people now being compliance officer
and just writing reports all day to the
regulators
right in the us uh fortunately actually
there's a redeeming feature um people
have been smarter
smarter than in europe about this
because the small banks don't have to
meet the basel requirements
but that's really recent that they let
them out of some of the more onerous
regulations but
the damage has been done because some of
these small banks
made loans outside of their footprint
to use your term and and they've got
huge amounts of commercial real estate
concentration on their balance sheets
uh that are not appropriate for the size
of bank
they are so you you have a situation in
the making that you're actually going to
lose more
small banks in this next downturn yes
yes
and in europe the rule has always been
that they all had to meet
even the smallest bank had to meet all
the complicated basel
basel iii uh before basel ii
um regulations and it had meant
that they had to the smaller ones had to
merge with bigger ones and and
banking uh was becoming more
concentrated so that's been the problem
and as a result of course that means the
small firms don't get the funding
don't get the local bank anymore to back
them
and that means they can't upgrade to the
latest technology that means
productivity goes down that's
what it means and that means your real
economic growth potential also goes down
if you then want to stimulate the
economy you will just
push it into acid markets you get also
inflation
which of course with the the various
measures since last year
under the covet heading is unfortunately
going to happen so these are all the
wrong developments when
the the simple fact is we can have
high stable sustainable economic
growth three percent four percent five
percent for the us is absolutely
possible
without inflation without crises
and actually without too much inequality
because the other advantage of having a
decentralized banking system with many
many small banks
is that essentially your inequality is
not going to be so bad
but the more the banking system gets
concentrated the more inequality you get
we see this in the uk
with five big banks dominating city of
london
and you know london city jobs in the
financial sector
of course the pay is way above the rest
of the country
and um inequality rises of course with
the asset
price bubble as well making those
much richer much faster who who have the
means to
to invest in assets and so on so all
these problems actually go back to the
structure of the banking system
and as you say unfortunately at the
moment in many countries we're on the
wrong train where
we're reducing the number of banks and
so where's this heading and this is
really scary if you think about this
because this trend is now only
accelerating and since 2020
um you know all these government
measures and restrictions
on almost every count it has accelerated
this trend
and there is now the further um threats
now coming up
because the central planners at the
central banks are now coming out
more openly and they're saying oh
actually we want to i mean we're bank
regulators
we're the umpire in the game but
actually now we want to play we want to
kick the ball ourselves you know and
um why well we want to compete with the
banks
they they want to make this less obvious
but this is really what it is so they
use a
slightly geeky explan explanation for
this they call it
cb dc central bank digital
digital currency what is it what is it
it's just a current account at the
central bank
for everyone so suddenly the central
banks are saying we want to be
bankers to the public now there has been
essentially an
implicit agreement between the central
banks and the banks
that goes back several centuries in most
countries because the u.s federal
reserve is only 100 years old and a bit
but in other countries where they're
older like england this is like a 300
year old
agreement namely of course the central
banks are powerful
because they're the banker of the banks
and they as regulators obviously they
can also shut down banks and so on they
have this power
but in exchange um the agreement was the
banks
are the ones that deal with the public
and the central banks don't deal with
the public
and also as we as we saw as explained in
the in the beginning
the banks are the ones that create the
money supply which gives us
economic growth but now
we have on the horizon now this proposal
that the central banks want to compete
with banks
by offering current accounts to the
public
and you can imagine what happens next in
fact the the federal reserve bank of
philadelphia put out the studies the
only one
of the central bank studies that wasn't
full of excitement like the others all
hailing this as the the latest great
development
they were cautioning they were saying
well hang on um this is likely to
drive banks out of business because all
the deposits
particularly if there's a bit of a
crisis or some some you know shock
will quickly move to the central bank
digital currency
which is then going to be considered the
safest
bank deposit and the banks will be out
of business
and of course add that to the trend
we've already seen that there's more
regulation on the banks
and of course find we haven't mentioned
it well you've mentioned interest rates
um this policy of lower and lower and
lower interest rates and also having a
flat yield curve
and in europe even crazy policy of
negative interest rates
both on the short and the long end for
countries like germany is absolutely
crazy
how how how does that um affect the
banks particularly the small banks well
especially the banks that do
traditional banking lending to companies
they need a
positive or if possible steep yield
curve
because they um you know they can then
lend at that higher
long-term interest rate to their
customers and that's their margin that's
how they earn money
but this traditional lending to the real
economy
has been driven out of business by the
central bankers flattening the yield
curve or inverting it
and pushing it down to zero or even
negative territory you can't earn money
what is left is what the big banks have
been doing
since 2008 they just borrow money
cheaply from the central bank and put it
into assets
asset markets various forms of financial
products and so on but
um and you can earn money on that sure
but that's not traditional banking and
it's not helping the real economy is not
generating jobs like
small bank lending to small firms does
so this is all
the trade is going as you say is going
in the wrong direction but it's it's
getting worse because they're adding
further momentum with the central bank
digital currency
and so ultimately you know if the number
of banks keeps this
you know keeps going down in the us in
the euro zone the way it has been going
down and now
likely will accelerate for the next
crisis around the corner
and then of course they will not rescue
the small banks
you know in europe they've got the new
bail-in policies
which essentially says all the big banks
they're special we're going to rescue
those
all the other banks the majority
thousands of small banks i was too bad
you know and and depositors even
above the payoff amount they will lose
their money this is what what they're
going to do
richard what you're describing though um
and i think the reason that there is
pushback
uh for a central bank digital currency
especially in the united states is
because
of the power of so many of our largest
banks and the pushback
but we have to remember that janet
yellen is a labor economist by training
and i could see her very easily
with unemployment possibly staying
stubbornly high she speaks often of
economic scarring
the permanent joblessness situation so i
could see her advocating for a
helicopter money to use a layman's term
type of solution
you get that by delivering money
directly to the people
with the exact mechanism that you were
describing but
there's also a byproduct if i'm not
mistaken and that's something that
is a furious debate right now and it
sounds like you're going there do you
think
this would cause inflation uh yes yeah i
mean that
i said this already in april last year
the measures they have been adopting the
central banks have been adopting
last year since march of a very
different
kind to the measures that were adopted
in 2008-2009
they're very different then in 2008 2009
i was not expecting inflation
some people were saying this is
inflationary qe um
and um and i was pointing out it's not
inflation is also not going to weaken
the dollar
but since 2020 the policies are very
different
and they are inflationary they're also
potentially going to weaken the dollar
further i was ready
negative on the dollar last year and
this could go
further so that's um
definitely on the horizon now could i
just
before we go into this because that is a
very interesting and important
discussion
just quickly finish off the the previous
discussion about the number of banks i
just want to add one more
example because you mentioned china and
and how this is
is always a good comparison well
because of course the trend as you
reduce the number of banks and as
central banks
um you know offer digital currencies the
number of banks will go down
rapidly and then potentially when
there's a crisis
then we will be left with really only
the central bank
that seems to be where the ecb wants to
be heading
the only bank in town well
this sort of system did exist before
where there's only one bank for a fairly
large economy
namely the soviet union that is the
soviet system the soviet union had one
bank
gosbank and it didn't really work very
well it wasn't a good system
now china under mao and
you know the earlier leaders um china
followed the soviet model
but then in 1978 deng xiaoping
became the new leader and he
was a pragmatist famously and he was
also an empirical guy you know what
works empirically you know i'm
interested in that and we want results
we want to deliver
and he conclude he looked the soviet
union this this is really
not working very well i'm not very
impressed with this
he looked at japan and he saw and in
fact he traveled to japan and
and literally spoke to people okay
what's your secret and he found out oh
it
is having many many small banks and
making sure through credit guidance that
it's used for productive purposes
business investment
well okay we'll do that thank you and
that's what he did
said and done um through i mean they
copied the window guidance credit
guidance policies from japan that the
central bank was running it's
in fact the people's bank of china is
the the only central bank left in the
world that
will admit officially that it's still
using credit guidance all the others
they're sort of hush-hush about it and
they pretend they're not doing this
um so what did he do when he came back
from japan
he created banks he established banks
credit unions community banks credit
associations
regional banks provincial banks
long-term investment banks specialized
banks development banks thousands and
thousands of banks
china now has just a bit less than
america but
over 4 000 banks in china and of course
the rest is history
uh you know the small banks lending to
small firms
uh that creates economic growth
double-digit economic growth for four
decades lifting more people out of
poverty than anywhere before in history
that was pretty amazing and it goes back
to the banking system so
now what are we doing instead of
learning the lessons from history
it seems we want to be introducing the
soviet system
and it's you know if you think it
through it really doesn't make any sense
we need to make sure banking systems
stay diverse
and we get lots of small banks and we
need the right regulatory environment we
need the right
monetary policy to encourage and allow
that so
current policy with this zero and
negative rates um they're very very
unhelpful
in fact can we quickly talk about
interest rates and then inflation would
be
um it would be clearer the inflation
picture
i mean i mentioned it earlier when we
talked about japan
when japan lowered interest rates for
the first time in 91 so everyone was
bullish on japan because that's the
standard thinking if you have lower
rates it's good for the economy good for
stock markets
and so well they've been lowering rates
for so long
um isn't it a good thing isn't that a
good thing well
what's the empirical record i mean this
story that
lowering rates boosts the economy and is
in other words there's a negative
correlation between interest rates and
growth
you know lower rates higher growth
higher rates lower growth so negative
correlation
and the causation running from interest
rates to growth right that's the claim
this has been repeated particularly by
central bankers by the journalists
writing it up by the economist and all
their theories
so many hundreds and thousands of times
in the last 50 years
that of course we all assume well of
course that's a
fact of life isn't it have you actually
seen any empirical studies that
demonstrate this
there aren't many in fact
mine is the first is published 2018
it's called reconsidering monetary
policy you can also google it's also
open access reconsidering monetary
policy my name
and in the journal ecological economics
many journals didn't like this at all
because
i thought it was fabulous there's so
many uh schools of thought and economics
there's the classical economists
like david ricardo adam smith then
there's the neoclassical economist like
alfred marshall
then we have the keynesian it comes like
keynes and his followers
uh in the postwar era tobin and and
people like that
then we had the monatorist milton
friedman uh we have
um all sorts of schools even alternative
schools there's the austrian school
um there's the post keynesian school and
of course the present day um
sort of supply ciders and real business
cycle economists
okay new classical economics okay now
there's
all these famously economists have all
different ideas but they all all these
schools including
the alternative like austrian and post
keynesia they all agree on one thing
namely what we just mentioned that if
you lower rates this will increase
investment increase economic growth is
good for the stock market good for the
economy if you
lower rates but if you raise rates it's
the opposite so the inverse correlation
between interest rates and growth
and causation from interest rates to
growth they all agree on this so this is
the foundation of
modern economics in the last three well
250 years let's say
but has it ever been empirically tested
no
can you believe this this is like my
first test in the 5000 year history of
banking i thought okay let's test this
empirically
and we took the data um
on the top economies of the us
japan germany and the uk
it has to be a longer time period so
half a century second half of the 20th
century
and we just look at the facts long
interest rates short interest rates
and gdp growth
what we find is that there is no
evidence
for an inverse negative correlation
there's a very very strong overwhelming
evidence
on all counts essentially of a positive
correlation
interest rates and economic growth are
positively correlated
now what about the timing you've got
granger causality and these these tests
of what happens first well it is
economic growth that happens first and
interest rates follow
so the the truth is the opposite of the
official
economic story in in in two dimensions
it's not lower rates lead to higher
growth its higher growth
leads to higher rates lower growth
leads to lower rates we have a positive
correlation
and the causation runs from economic
growth to interest rates and that of
course in one go
blows out of the water all claims by
central banks about the interest rate
policy the need for their
interest rate policy the need for lower
rates why do they have lower rates well
because they've
crushed the economy because daniel the
the financialization you mentioned
earlier going on for a long time in the
u.s that means
the real economy has not delivered much
growth
economic growth in the real economy has
been suppressed in most industrialized
countries in the last
20 30 years and that means they that
we have lower rates so we need to push
up economic growth
then we can also have higher rates
rates always follow growth why do we
have negative rates in europe because
they've got negative growth in many
european countries thanks to ecb policy
okay that raises a number of questions
namely why do central banks
still talk about interest rates the
short answer is they want to
confuse you it's a smoke screen distract
attention from their real policies it's
also an alibi
or we're trying to help look we're
working really hard we've just lowered
rates again
we're really trying to help the economy
when actually of course they know
jolly well that rates follow growth and
the economy's just gone down and that's
why the law and grades following the
economy
but the other question then is what
really drives economic growth
it's not interest rates because that
follows growth it's of course what we
discussed at the outset
money creation it's qua the quantity of
credit creation
in the banking system and for productive
measures
exactly and and of course central banks
have control over that
they don't really need to use interest
rates for that um they can talk to the
banks the big banks and they do
and there's other ways of incentivizing
banks that are not so visible
to encourage them to increase lending
sometimes or reduce lending
when needed and that's what's driving
the economy and of course central banks
are very much aware
of the quantity of bank credit creation
and their own credit creation and that's
what's driving the economy
now therefore they have no excuse as we
now
turn to this very sad chapter
now they're adding inflation to our
economic woes and they have no excuses
because
they know if you increase credit
creation
for consumptive purposes for consumption
you're going to get inflation
and this unfortunately is increasingly
happening with these
post-covet measures in 2008
um you know lots of central banks
were also aggressive and expanded
and called it qe by the way i don't know
whether you're aware but
that's qe quantitative easing actually
something i proposed
in 1995 in tokyo
yes you you coined the term yes and it
had but it had a very specific
definition
because first i've been earlier i've
been forecasting this banking crash in
japan and the long recession
but then i also then designed policies
to get out of this so
i realized the best way to get out of
this
post bank credit created acid bubble
banking crisis you know where the
banking system is down on his knees
burdened with huge bad debts
is is a new policy you need the central
bank to come in
with a set of policies and you can very
quickly
move out of there which has been done in
some countries not in japan
unfortunately they didn't listen to me
number one you can get rid of the bad
debts in the banking system
really the central banker should take
some responsibility
because they should have stopped bank
credit creation for asset purchases
in its tracks when it happens and gets
out of hand and therefore
you know the moral hazard principle
those who mess up should pay up
well so the central bank should really
pay up and that's also the solution the
central bank can just move the bad debts
from
the balance sheets of the banks onto its
own balance sheet
but that's precisely what happened with
maiden lane and
exactly the united states and so on
exactly so the central bank can purchase
the non-performing assets
at obviously prices that are above
market value well they claim we don't
know what market value is so
whatever can be face value the central
bank has no cost
and this actually doesn't create
inflation either that's what i
recommended for japan that's my qe
the original qe now in the 90s ben
bernanke was part of these debates we
had
the central bank needs to step in create
money to purchase assets from banks
to non-performing assets from banks
that's the central bank money creation
that's how
it should be done then of course you
want to encourage the banks to lend
again you do this
um through this measure by cleaning up
the balance sheet
the central bank can directly also try
to create money by purchasing
assets from non-banks fine
but more importantly get the banks to
lend again because it's all bank credit
creation that delivers growth
and one more measure i proposed in japan
i call this it's part of qe i call this
enhanced debt management
the the government can kick-start bank
credit
creation and they should have done this
in japan they should have done it in
spain
and in the uk by simply
stopping the issuance of government
bonds well hang on
how do they fund their deficit spending
or their huge
you know deficit overhang how do they
find it well by
borrowing from banks through loan
contracts which are not tradable don't
have to be marked to market
and therefore expanding bank credit
creation in a very
smart way and
they should have done this in the
european you know the sovereign debt
crisis where you had this
doom um link between banks and sovereign
markets um and essentially
the government should have stopped
issuing bonds
imagine what that does to the bond
market suddenly wow the bond market is
really strong no more supply
so it's very good for the bond market
clearly if you don't
push any more supply out there of by
issuing new bonds you stop
issuing bonds um and instead
the government borrows from banks
through loan contracts which gives
business to banks
the banks need business they need to
boost their balance sheets again
that means there's money creation now
because
bonds issued by the government that are
not purchased by the banking system
don't create money
and in many countries actually pension
funds asset management companies are big
bond
buyers that's not money creations is not
helping in a downturn
but for buying from banks you're
directly
creating money for gdp transactions for
um transactions that will boost your
nominal gdp you increase tax revenues
so that was the third part of this qe i
proposed now
ben bernanke seemed to have listened he
was the only central banker when the
2008 crisis came
and suddenly they wanted my qe they all
said we're going to do qe but he was the
only one
who implemented at least this first
crucial step of
getting rid of the non-performing assets
in the banking system
unfortunately obviously with the buyers
okay we help the big guys
predictable that should have been
avoided you help everyone in a fair
transparent manner
have also the small banks it turns out
the small banks actually weren't in
trouble because
they were not engaged in mostly they
were not engaged in the
you know the blow up transactions the uh
subprime
the sliced and diced you know um credit
strategies
investments um
um but he did it and and that's why
the u.s economy recovered first and
fastest and strongest after the 2008
crisis
if you compare to other countries
because the ecb bank of england you know
all the other countries and also even
even japan they didn't do this japan
then by 2013
woke up to this i went to tokyo to meet
mr kuroda who i'd met already in
in around when was it
when he was still at the ministry of
finance and i told him look
this what you should do you should stop
the issuance of government bonds
and borrow from the banks you need but
that's proper qe
um and so but i saw him again when he
was central bank governor
and um it seems he listened because
they have perhaps not quite as
aggressively as as they could have done
it but they have increased bank credit
creation
in japan as well but much later 2013
essentially is when they
when they did that i mean after 20 years
of recession
uh quite unnecessary recession so
um but the policies last year 2020 and
and
and potentially also this year are of a
different kind
because then we had no no inflationary
pressure because when the central bank
even purchased non-performing assets
from banks that doesn't create any money
money is created when the banking system
including the central bank
creates money and injects into
non-banking sector right
then we have money creation then it
depends what is it used for assets
or consumption but when the central bank
inside the banking system
cleans up the bank balance sheets you're
just reallocating money in the banking
system
that itself doesn't create inflation and
it didn't and the dollar also didn't
rise
i didn't fall um it rolls um so
but 2020 is different you know in 2008
bank credit was literally collapsing
because of the interbank market freezing
because everyone was concerned about you
know are you holding some lehman's
papers and so on party risk yes of
course exactly so they all
okay we stay out of the interbank market
it's very little known but
banking is a funny business because you
need
banks to cooperate for banking to work
right we talked about say a transfer
let's do a bank transfer
of course it's not no money is
transferred right um
the banks are just doing a booking of
their
liabilities to the public
between them and they need the interbank
market to do this
and when that freezes you do have a
problem so
bank credit was collapsing and then when
the central bank steps in
you know in total actually in total
credit creation was still shrinking
initially 2009. so there's there
couldn't be
inflation but 2020 is so different
because bank rate was really strong
in in january in february we're talking
four five six percent bank credit growth
okay so we're not talking about a
collapse in in bank credit
um and then these
these measures were introduced from
march onwards
where the federal reserve itself
created credit but also it forced the
banks to create
credit and bank credit creation then
jumped on top of already growing very
strongly
and that's a different situation so
that's why we have
the strongest money supply expansion in
well one of the strongest in post-war
history or perhaps in fed history
um and it's it's very likely that this
will
feed back into inflation because of
course we have also these
um you know government guarantees we
have
um payments which you know to some
extent are necessary but they shouldn't
necessarily be paid with money creation
to support people um and
therefore a bigger chunk a much bigger
chunk is going to go into consumption
now
that is more more than what happened in
2010 where we did not have inflation so
it's a different scenario
well um richard i think on that note you
you've resolved the biggest burning
question and that is
that we are indeed going to get
inflation uh i'd i'd love to
uh i'd love to circle back in about a
year
um and and dive deeper into
what we're going to see here in the next
12 months
um but i i so appreciate your time today
uh this was riveting i
recommend your your book and the
documentary is absolutely
fascinating um and i look forward to
doing this again
thank you very much if we're lucky in a
year's time um we will still only have
modest inflation it will have ticked up
is already now ticking up
you know um so it will still be modest
and we then can discuss comparisons with
um
100 years ago in germany weimar germany
because you know there is a
we have some time hopefully if we're
lucky in this run-up to inflation but i
think there is particularly if you put
the political scenario
together with the with this and the uh
central bank digital currency and the
goal to reduce the number of banks
and of course central bank digital is
supposed to be linked to
some kind of global numerology
architecture financial architecture
therefore um you know it's possible that
weimar style high inflation even
hyperinflation
could be a scenario that could be
encouraged by some
and so yeah we probably will still be
talking about inflation i think but
let's see
thank you very much absolutely thank you
for your time i appreciate it
you